- Okay.
- [Interviewer] All right, Crystal.
Crystal, where are you from originally?
- Palm Springs, California.
- Palm Springs.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
Did you grow up with both parents?
- I grew up with my mom and stepdad,
my two younger brothers, my half brothers.
And then, I left my mom's
when I was a teenager.
Moved in with my father,
going to high school
with my two older brothers,
and lived with him until I graduated.
And then, once I graduated in Arizona, and
started working right
away, right out of school.
- [Interviewer] What
kind of work did you do?
- I was in the restaurant business.
Hostessing, serving.
- [Interviewer] Now, at some point,
drug use came into the picture, right?
- For me, or for--
- For you.
- Yeah, it did.
Sometimes at high school,
you go to parties.
And I started smoking weed and
drinking a lot, and then I
cut back senior year, really.
Didn't party too much.
And then, I got out of high
school and I started working.
And then, my off days.
After a couple of years, I was working.
It wasn't right away.
I started using.
And then, more and more
was on the weekends.
And then, I would get time
off and go out of town
and then, party then, also.
Just all sorts of different things.
- [Interviewer] In the
restaurant business,
it kind of goes hand-in-hand.
- Right, you meet different people
and you go hang out with
them after work or whatever.
And they wanna, "try a line of
coke," you know what I mean,
or "come try some ecstasy."
And it's all there, they want
to pay for it, so why not?
- [Interviewer] And what is
the drug that you're using
more recently?
- I always like to try everything.
Heroin.
I liked it more and more.
Felt more relaxed.
I didn't try it as something
to escape from anything.
I was depressed and going
through a lot of emotional pain,
and it just felt like I was always angry
and just didn't feel right,
as being me like normal.
I needed something I
didn't really have friends.
I needed something to, I
don't know feel better.
Normally, you wake up every
day and you have your routine.
But me, I just would wake
up and just be sad and angry
and didn't want to do anything,
no energy, and I don't know.
So, I tried it one day
and I really liked it,
and I kept doing it, and
doing it, and doing it
more and more, and then--
- And here you are.
- Yeah, exactly.
I stopped, and started
again, stopped and started.
I've indulged in cocaine,
more than a few times, more
than at least 10 times.
Crack, I tried a handful of times.
Those are all definitely
social drugs, really.
But like I said, I went
more towards the heroin,
more of a relaxed type of person.
- [Interviewer] What about meth?
- Meth?
- Crystal meth?
- Yeah, I've tried that.
Sometimes I do heroin into crystal meth,
right after, yeah.
'Cause some people I was around
didn't use heroin, they just used crystal.
- [Interviewer] And what do
you do for money out here?
- I do different things.
- [Interviewer] What
a lot of the girls do?
- Hustle, that's what
they would call it, right?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Slang, to to speak, as
people are here today,
in the streets.
Long and short of it, prostitution.
Unfortunately, it is illegal.
- [Interviewer] Tell me what that's like.
How does a girl decide that
that's what she's gonna do?
That's gotta be--
- It's actually, really something
you think about and you,
I don't know, I've thought
about it for like, and I
I kind of just sort of take judge.
Like other women do that.
Or, you know, people always talk down like
that's the lowest of low.
You can go as far
as the child or degrading
yourself as a woman.
And I just think like, well, I mean
if you're safe, you wear protection.
Right. And I mean to do it
all the time, it's one thing.
But to do it
I guess when you need it for
certain things is another
that's what I found myself having to turn
to it at times because you
know, I'm not here by myself.
I don't know anybody,
you know, and I'm hungry
and people don't want just
give you anything money.
They, I mean, it's all here.
It's the hardest ever anywhere
I've ever been in my life.
It took me two or three days.
I think it was two days to
get a dollar, $1 out here
seriously being totally
more and more, you know
not even messed up.
Okay. And it was really hard and people
wouldn't let me use their
cell phone or nothing.
I'm just like, this is
really going to get bad.
But point is, is that, you
know, I go out there and it's 20
25 bucks for sexual intercourse, you know?
And you don't know if they're a cough
you don't know what they're up to.
And it's scary.
You know, I've had a gun
to my head threatens to
even use without protection.
And that's one of my
biggest fears it happened
and we threw a little loop,
you know, it just taught me
I got to budget my money better
when I do get it, you know
as far as partying and things like that.
But I get money every month
I get income from welfare.
Right. But you only get so much.
So there's 30 days in
a month then, you know
- At some point when you're
addicted and you need a fix
and it becomes that drive to get
that fixed becomes so strong that
- Others resort to, you know,
I've seen people with robbery.
I have people came up and Robbie, you know
right away on mean, they
asked me to go make the money.
And I don't even know
I have, and I've gotten
out of a car like straight
up, Rami just took my money.
And I felt those people like other cars
they know I have money.
So that's my stuff.
Cause now if I go to do it
again, I don't know who's around.
Or if I am going to get robbed,
I don't give him my money.
I'll get beat up or he
knows what will happen.
So it's very scary.
It is.
Yeah. So you just gotta be careful.
I try not to resort to that.
I don't have to, you know
but it's scary seeking
an attempt to though
you know, by yourself, you don't know
you heard about the
shootings and sorry to stay
at murders and hit and
runs and things like that.
That happened all the
time on these streets
on the next block, the next block
like it's every day event.
Yeah. And wow.
It really makes you think what an area
you know what I mean?
- No big deal.
It's just
- And it's just like, you know
it's people you would literally run
into or talked to you,
just like, well, you know
one day you see somebody
the next day you don't.
I mean, it literally happens like that.
I have, I haven't arrested.
I was a wrong place, wrong time.
I was in the tent,
excuse me, cleaning a 10.
And they were coming
in and they did a sweep
and they came in and they just walked
out in the tent and they
found things in the tent.
They weren't mine, but I couldn't prove it
wasn't my time because I didn't
have ID or anything on me.
Right. And the owner wasn't there.
So they said, well,
you're the only one here.
So you're accountable.
And I said, Oh my God,
that's I believe, well
I don't have a record.
I don't know where.
And they said, well, we're
going to get you a name.
I don't know what is
they call them baggies
of powdered substances.
They have to test them.
I still have to go to court.
But the told me what they are.
They say it's meth, possession
of meth, possibly cocaine.
Some, I don't know,
weapons tonight, needles
all sorts of things.
And I can't find it because
I have nothing else to prove.
So they are, they're not together.
My biological.
Yeah, they do.
They do.
I don't keep in touch with
them as much as I used to.
I've been out here almost eight months.
I have a son he's going
to be five in January.
My mom, I do.
But being out here, it's a lot harder.
You know what I mean?
I can't commute back and forth.
And like when I lived out
there, it was a lot easier
because it was down the
street, a couple blocks away.
But out here, obviously it's a lot harder.
I attempted to go back a
couple of times, right.
By getting rides and it just didn't work
out and then getting a bus
ticket and then lost my ID.
Right. Or it got stolen doing it again.
And then I misplaced it.
So it's a process all
over again to get back
but I can take the bus and get back.
But I was here going
through all that I've gone
through with day in and day out.
The welfare system here does
help the homeless a lot more
than anywhere else I've been
even though I haven't been
homeless anywhere else.
But so they're offering help
out here to lend myself a job employment
and things like that.
So I'm gonna take it
up and continue myself
out here on the better end
of the spectrum, you know
see what I can do with that.
But like I said, it's still a struggle.
I don't know what tomorrow
is going to bring her
the next day or the next day.
So it sounds all good
but you don't really know
until it happens, right?
- Yeah. So is your cyber asking
you why you're not with him?
- No. He's just always looking for
and what am I going to see him next?
You know, I don't like the
fact when I maybe Christ
you know, it's sad, you
know, he's there because I
I moved away to find
more stable environment
definitely environment altogether.
Right. But unfortunately
in doing so it backfired.
Cause my parents are like,
well, now that you're out there
and you're running around
everywhere, you know
cause I don't have an exact plan.
Right. They feel I'm unstable.
So now they're making it harder
for me to try to get my son back.
Right. Which I get it
but that looks like
they've lost all trust.
And me being like I'm out here
and they don't know
everything that's going on.
They kind of turned it
on me a little bit when
I'm out there and you
know, I'm starting my day
and I'm hungry and I have
no other resources or money
and I'm thinking, okay, well
what am I going to do to eat?
I mean, I smoked cigarettes.
How am I going to do that?
50 cents a cigarette or whatever.
They've definitely don't give them to you.
Then it becomes like I feed
with nicotine or, you know
I don't really feel good today.
I know that I'm going to check these types
of people that like use,
you know what I mean?
That's going to bring in more money.
Okay. Okay.
Well, you know what?
I don't feel too great.
I think I need to go get some more all
or I'm going to go get some more, you know
and I'm going to feel a lot better.
Well, this person is around.
I got to go to this person.
We got sweat.
It cost 20 more dollars.
Oh great.
Okay. So now what, now
that's the food on top
of the fixed or on top of
whatever I'm going to buy.
Right. And then cigarettes too.
That's quite a bit of money.
So now it's not only one person.
So now as a Christian
that's what two or three people
to try to, you know, look
look the part and get myself
up or whatever I'm out, you
know, and being convincing
I'm not going to Rob him and
you're not going to hurt me.
So it's also plays a part on
me as a woman being degraded.
And you know
actually I've had time
from during intercourse.
The guy's actually
telling me how do you feel
to grading yourself, doing the lowest job
lowest type of work you
could do as a woman.
And I'm just like, it's serious.
You know, I'm sitting
there like, I want you to
enjoy yourself and you're
paying for it and it's gone.
How do you look at yourself
every day in the mirror?
Like the sweat while
I'm doing it to survive.
And he was just totally
enjoying putting me down.
It was like, wow.
Yeah, it is hard because it's like
are you serious about
things to talk about?
Or, you know, and that
really hurt, kinda hurt me
but I can't show that, you know
- This is a choice.
- Right. Right.
And I, and I'm just
like, like either I'm not
good enough to do it.
Right. Or they're not into me
or they're trying to
get something out of it.
Right. So
- Something
- You know what I mean?
Or they say, or I would no offense.
I was raised in a house with
women or I've been around
I've worked the streets for years.
So I know what it's like,
if you're afraid, excuse me.
After her.
And she go work and I think
they're just playing me.
So, you know, I don't even want to pay.
It's not worth my time.
Oh really?
I threw like, what an hour already?
You know what I mean?
You made me do all these different things.
Nice. Not into it, you know, you know
so I want to get really mad and lash out
but I don't, you know, and
then I just lose out on money.
And when you do that sucks.
So it is, it is very hard.
Definitely think twice
before I make certain
decisions and stay safe
- Wake up crazy alive
feeling to come around.
- It is, it is because
I haven't completely
found myself and what I'm happy doing
I am, but I feel a lot older, you know
I don't feel as wise as
I should be, you know
like I haven't taken in all
that, all that I've learned
and applied it directly to my
life yet that in time I will.
All right.
Thank you.
I appreciate time.